hey theo this is uh salim
coming at you from victoria british
columbia in canada
salim and man thank you canada for being
you
you know sometimes i fall asleep at
night i think about canada bro
i'll be honest with you dude no homo bro
no snomo
but i think about canada
and i think sometime i just i'll lay in
bed i'll just think about damn canada
bro
and i think about a newborn baby just
riding naked on a
just on a damn reindeer's back
and just looking for god bro both of
them a little the little babies on the
back of the reindeer and
he just looking for the lord
and there's just something beautiful
about that [ __ ] bro
and i'll be honest i'll be the first to
tell you i didn't think canada was a
real place when i was growing up
when i was young somebody said hey a
wolf you know
a wolf attack they had us drawing at
school it was a picture of a wolf
attacking a boy
and it said canada on it
i said damn boy so i thought canada was
just a place where america where we
you know practice safety equipment where
we mailed safety equipment to see if it
worked and they mailed it back
i thought it was a company you know kind
of a you know probably a 3.5 star
company
out of 5 stars but
that's a that's a myth man i've been
smoking methamphetamines bro if i'm
thinking that
i've been getting high on
methamphetamines if i've been thinking
that because canada
canada is amazing
if you meet somebody from canada bro hug
them shake their hand
[ __ ] them treat them well baby
feed them you know massage them
garage them bro put them in your garage
you feel me i'm saying do something for
them because they're good people
anyway thank you saleem onward and uh
i have a thing going on i recently met
this girl that i really like and uh the
issue though
is she is very covet conscious i guess
not an issue that makes sense
and um basically we go on a couple days
we're hanging out from a distance
and like we can't really you know make
any physical contact or
kiss each other hug or whatever and
that's tough i feel like
for me i don't know what you think about
no physical contact in a
relationship and also i'm heading back
to
ontario outside of toronto in a
couple months so i don't know
you know really what i'm doing or why
so you're canadian she's afraid of covid
this is like uh snomeo and hachu
liet you know she's scared of something
you really
you know and you from the great dub in
baby
you feel me that white north bro that
blanco up top gang [ __ ] homework
but uh the circumstances point no but i
like her and i like seeing her so
love to hear your thoughts um love the
podcast you're a hilarious guy and
he's taught me a lot just listening to
you talk
gang gang brother gang baby
thank you saleem
um and let me tell you i'll say this
first of all man i think
you know this is a beautiful story
and this is why i listen to this podcast
because sometimes it reminds me
that there is there there is still
a a human part of life
sometimes it does sometimes it don't
remind me of anything
but sometimes it reminds me that there's
still this element of
people there's still this
this fabric
inside us that
that wants to be seen
and that fabric a lot of times it's it's
like uh
the text it's like the textile of just
the of the human condition
um and sometimes it's
it's fun and sometimes it's real and
sometimes it's tragic and sometimes it's
sometimes it's alive and sometimes it's
dead almost
but it's it's just
bare and it's nice
this something about this does that for
me this
this call because it just
you know not every relationship is come
over here
and let me look up your booty
you know there's a lot of love out there
that still has this old-fashioned
wagon wheel kind of environment
you know there's a lot of love out there
that's like hey i met you and i'm
thinking about you
and it's not a million texts a day and
it's not a
you know look i'll be honest i met a
girl a couple months ago and we met up
in a park
and you know i tried to get to see her
tits from about 20 feet away she said no
and she drove off and she thought i was
probably a piece of [ __ ]
she was probably right
but you're doing something else man you
have a really there's a love thing going
on there
and you're just kind of contemplating
well what if i i'm you know
i could lose this girl i could go on you
know i have to go
and that's called extradition when you
got to leave the country
and i'm you know i'm glad that not
everybody's allowed to stay
unfortunately that
you know if you run over here with a
damn hatchet
and shoot up a dollar general they let
you stay but
you know you're a decent canuck over
here doing you know trying to fall in
love and they
you know but those are the rules but um
what are we talking about just now but
love man um
there's something special about that
you know there used to be something
special about when somebody wasn't
around just thinking about them
man i remember i had a big crush on this
girl katie
and people called her kind of fat katy i
think but i just called her just katie
and if she was fat man uh good that
meant there was more of her bro
because i was in love with her
and uh and i wrote katie on my pillow
and someone would just go
lay in my bed and just hug this pillow
as hard as i could
and i just hoped that somehow she just
knew
how much i just cared about her
and uh
and somehow in that little process of me
hugging this pillow it was
that was the old school like just
texting or stalking on instagram that
was the old
that was it was a real visceral thing
you know back in the day somebody would
get a knife and they would just go out
to a park bench
and just be like i'm a [ __ ] bridget
then they would just write that in there
and that you know it was just that meant
something
it was putting it out into the world
without putting it right into somebody's
damn ear hole
and it gave the world a chance to say
okay i'ma
maybe this will land over by him or
maybe it won't
we let the world play a role
it used to be you put your feelings onto
a kite oh
it used to be you'd put your feelings
like you you know you'd take them
you'd blow them into a balloon of sorts
and just let them off into the world and
maybe they would land on the person's
heart they were intended for maybe they
wouldn't
but now it's everything so direct we
just take it and we write it on the
arrow
you know damn it i love you
and i'm my pervert and you just now you
just fire it right at him
and we just the world if we don't let
the world work
we don't let the world have a say
anymore
so i feel you man there's something
magical about if you go
or if you stay or if there's something
magical about being at a distance
because we used to always have to be at
a distance
you couldn't permeate someone as
immediately as you could now
you had to kind of let the world play a
role
but i um all where your head's at and i
love where your heart's at man
and i think one thing you can do this is
a great time for some romance
whether this works out or not
it's a great time you know uh to do
something like a do a
do a uh scavengers hunt
you know you could do something sweet
you could um
you know put a message in a bottle and
throw it in her yard
you know you could do something like
that most some mow a message messaging
regress you know
let me hit that you wrote it over there
but it's a chance man it's a real chance
to do something kind of sweet i think um
yeah uh and you could do a do a um
a poem use your words that's a great
idea
use your words you know write her a
letter write her a letter about how you
feeling sexually
do her a poem you know maybe maybe uh
sex
sex feet away
this is for you baby this calls sex feet
away
i want that booty but the air got
diseases
i want that cuda but we gotta bleach our
creases
i want that monkey
and i want it on my tonsils but i don't
want you to die
baby i'm covered conscious
gang baby hit her with that
hit her with that bam that word hammer
dog
but yeah use your words use your
feelings and let it ride man
mail it to her
mail it to her stand out
but thank you for that question man in
that call gang [ __ ] praise god man
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah